i looked and she was like looking down
like that and i was like oh i'm sorry
she's like oh it's okay it's okay i
looked to my brother he was
smiling
i looked to my brother he was smiling
from ear to ear i wanted to get up and
spark him i wanted to rock his jaw off
[Music]
i've done that one before yeah yeah i
actually have isn't it yeah
wow yeah i can't remember obviously
remember
but you've definitely done that before
that's oh geez louise
wow that's mad oh god okay
um so guys welcome
sng episode 99 so you already know
what's around the corner one away
one away one away one away bro one away
for that
hundredth episode of big century so guys
um pre um
disclaimer not even disclaimer like free
episode 100
i'm just going to say a little thanks
again for everything um
we're going to have some fun with the
episode 100. it's going to be a good
laugh
um hopefully you guys can
chill along with us um maybe there'll be
sip zips involved maybe there weren't
i don't know we'll see it is a bit it's
been a massive request
so we'll make a deal with you guys if
you guys are willing to do the sip tips
with us
we will um we'll jump on that for you
guys so
um get your your tequila and your
pineapple juice ready
uh for next week because it's popping
off this is it's popping off
um so as always guys
patreon hit up that patreon guys
big things pop in uh over a patreon so
jump them over there you already know
the drill
it's three pound a month
equals ten pence a day standard standard
bro
run the pizza cheaper the chips run the
beauty is cheaper
yeah man run the peter sng man come on
cheaper than chips
[Music]
come on summer merch as well guys is
around the corner
uh we're just a few weeks away from that
launch um
that's exciting these designs are filthy
sick
um so yeah these ones are going to fly
off
i think these ones are do you think
these ones are your favorite so far
would you say i
would say you would say i would say
there's there these ones are your the
they're more original yeah yeah yeah a
lot more original the first
the first season obviously we're getting
the ground running you know finding our
foundation finding our feet the second
one
okay we can kind of tell that we've
upgraded but this one is about to drop
you men ain't ready you're my name ready
human ain't ready you mind it ready so
um get excited for that guys
obviously i know um we're gonna make
sure there's a a couple i know it's a
summer edition we're gonna make sure
there's a few
few warmer things out there we know some
of you don't have the lavish sun
yeah true true summer winter whatever
you might live in darkness so
i can't remember it's what is is our
summer australia's winter yeah
it's literally thinking that just now
okay so it's cold in australia right now
it will be pretty cold right now yeah
cool so yeah we'll throw in some
sweatshirts
and hades for you guys as well yeah um a
few cold folk over there
but what's the winner though it's
australia at the end of the day it's
still pretty cold i believe is it yeah
it gets cold
yeah i believe it gets built but when
it's hot it's disgusting yeah hot it's
like not survivable
yeah there's there was because there
over there i heard
um that obviously there they've just got
mad open space
so if you get like lost you know in like
in the in-betweeners
two yeah they got lost in australia yeah
apparently that's literally a death
sentence
yeah of course you can be there for days
bro no one will find you i can't
go past with days nah i couldn't be how
can you just
they need to barricade that off that
can't be open to rain you know what i
mean
my lip just can't walk out of
civilization at the end of nowhere
bro they have to barricade that they
just die man
it's crazy it's a wild concept it's a
while it is a world concept
it's just so much land and i think they
only use like 25 30
of it really something stupid like that
wow
i'm surprised some abu dhabi might have
gone over there just built it to see
you got all this space just let me do
all that build something i never
monopolized
yeah hotels couple mansions yeah if i
was a billionaire i'd be
up in australia just building [ __ ] they
probably won't even
i was gonna say they're probably gonna
be able to like facilitate stuff in
there because of how hot it is but then
why is [ __ ] boiling bro dubai gets
hot
like it's the baby yeah they can't
handle it in the summer it makes them
people leave dubai during summer to come
to warmer colder places yeah they come
to england they've got houses here
i remember when i used to work at dave
lloyd i think i told you before all they
do every july bro
it was that do you buy money you're bro
i'm not even joking you'll see one
person walk in
and you think hmm you get a sense yeah
yeah you're like
okay and they're just like oh i want to
join and they've got like a bit of an
accident anything
um yeah yeah and then write their name
down
and their address and you just like gang
this is it so you come in as the first
one first one wanders in by themselves
next thing you know bro families
families
families all from dubai they bought a
house in milton keynes
and they're there for the summer and
they've just signed up to health clubs
and
whatever and they just spent money
spent money bro they used to pay my
commission for that month
oh some money bro they just paid some
gold random credit card that didn't even
work
like it was weird like it wouldn't work
in the card machine he had to go like
pressed all the buttons and all the
years long he entered the bro thousands
of pounds on the spot wow
yeah wow and they literally said that
they've all got houses in
kingston because it gets too hot over
there you can't bear you can't go
outside
oh that's unbelievable the homeless
they must i don't speak in dubai there's
so many people everywhere
i would've thought they would just get
rid of them
why because i don't know i don't know
i just thought they would just not have
it no
bro there's the homeless people ever
like i know there's times people
everywhere
okay let's let's take dubai as um a city
center because that's what it is right
um there might not be that many homeless
people
in the smack bang middle of dubai um but
probably on the outside okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what i meant though
like on road yeah i would just imagine
that these men are trying to keep it so
pristine yeah that's just like homeless
man now that can't run
you you're going somewhere else yeah
yeah
i don't know um i don't know i don't
know
um
oh god sometimes when you sip that thing
it's like it revives you it does it
literally does
like you know where you get the first
lick on the sloppy top where they lick
you out first one yeah yeah
how did you shiver
yes bro the monster when his ice cold it
just touches your lips
and you're like it's it it lets you know
everything's gonna be all right
no matter what situation yeah if you
crack open the ice cold muscle
especially the white ones
because they're just not there's nothing
too fancy about it yeah is that a
neutral one
that's neutral okay it tastes like in my
opinion the closest thing i can remind
it to people
say it tastes like little i don't think
it tastes like a little i love little i
know i love to a little too but i don't
think it tastes like i think it tastes
more
spritey than a little b but it's not
sprite
it has much more flavor than sprite but
i wouldn't you can't place like a
tang to it it just tastes nice okay
so yeah when you sip it
the neutral basic foundation why and
you're just like
okay okay like i can do this
today i can do this if you ain't got it
and you're just there with nothing i
don't know how you do this
oh bro you just sit down sit down and
drink well i can't do
caffeine i need the caffeine bro i can't
do it
yeah i work with this girl um
and she uh she's brazilian and um she
obviously drinks coffee all their men
drink coffee
and i remember when i started there the
other month
yeah you're like oh uh we had a meet and
greet
i'm gonna get the coffees in like how'd
you like your coffee because i don't
drink coffee bro
and he was like oh okay and then uh anna
she came she brought in the coffees she
was oh james i didn't get one for you
sorry
like i wasn't on the i ordered a list
because i sent her out to get it and i
was like score i don't drink coffee she
was like
do you have a life in this strong
portuguese accident like
do you have a life that's a pigment
you're not smack
you don't even know me
[Laughter]
you have a life and i was like you man
don't understand this
monster level you man don't get it
there's a difference you men don't get
it and then
we had another meeting the other day she
had a long day
and then um she was like oh james
she was going to a car she's like oh
james i've got something today i was
thinking of you and i was thinking
what and um she went and i can't recall
that monster cam
and i was like welcome welcome welcome
to the game you can't go back from that
you can't taste that and get the buzz
that you get and think i want a coffee
now
no
they're so uninventive with their names
but you under once you've tasted it you
understand why it's called ultra red
because you say what does it taste like
you just say it just says red
it just tastes red it just tastes like
ultra red bro and then they've got a
blue one
a light blue one i'm pretty sure it's
called ultra blue and literally if you
taste it
you ask anyone who's had the white one
you give him this blue one the ultra
blue and you say what does it taste like
to say
it just tastes like a blue white one i
don't know what they're doing to my
palette
no they're making me too binary bro a
blue
white one it just tastes like a blue
white one it doesn't make any sense
until you end the monster game
and then you realize like wow this is
why they call it these stupid names
because it's exactly what it tastes like
it tastes like red
it tastes like blue it's like juicy
water it literally tastes like juicy
water yeah
yeah bro and it's a juicy water you're
like why is it called juicy where you
taste it it's like raw this is actually
juicy water
there's no other way to describe it
there's literally no other way to
describe it
i'd love to be in the boardroom when
they came up with that name
i would have been livid
this is a new product what is it i've
got we're gonna go with juicy water
what do i pay you my fault let you work
out what do i pay you literally
juicy water yeah juicy water and you
taste taste it taste it
yes that is actually juicy water
you man need to jump on the juicy juice
saves breeze juicy water
oh free promo bro bro it's the same
owner because i can't find it anywhere
else i can't find it anywhere about
sainsbury's and they only find the small
ones but
for that summer fruits flavor or
whatever it is bro only the small ones
i think they've got lemon and lime in
the big one yeah well they do you know
i know you've been hunting it too yeah
i've never been a summer freeze day here
because i live in the light that's dead
ass living alive bro
once brought me that summer fruit
i hate it man i always check to see if
they're going to change it up they don't
do it there's someone through
anything's in the little thing they know
it's a hot commodity yeah it's two years
they can't yeah they can't put a big
bowl that i the way i feel about juicy
water
is how i used to feel about sunny d back
in the day oh
my god sunny delight bro bro the
original recipe
there must have been crack cocaine in
there 100
100 it had kids bugging
sonny reckon the day had kids bargain
they had to take it off the shelves bro
i would smack a man for that sunny d my
dad used to get
my mom wouldn't let us have it bro my
dad used to give it get the little ones
put in our
box i wouldn't even eat i would just
slurp that this was way
before tropicana yeah yeah yeah sunny
deep before tropica
ah and they used to do flake different
flavors leds right
i think so i only stuck with the basic
yellow man they had a few variants
i can't remember it wasn't too
extravagant and a couple ones
but sunny d man it was turning kids
orange in it
piercing everything it was [ __ ] with
people yeah bro
back in it bro and i don't blame my
brother it tasted like
meth it tasted like heroin bro it tasted
so
good it was incredible and you just plug
it
non-stop you couldn't stop you couldn't
stop once you started it wasn't cracked
because it's one of them ones in it to
pull them around
because they had the massive oasis
circle yes bro and once you started
chugging it
you can't stop my parents would have to
drapes it from my lips
they dragged my hand like this you
didn't stop
[Music]
[Music]
it made no sense it's like literally
like crack cocaine
oh and then they have to change the
recipe now they're making no money
because they still sell it now i still
said it i saw her in the superpocket
every day i was thinking
it's so it's not it's so not advertised
anymore yeah
bro the fda approved sonny d
no one gives off give me the cracks do
you man that's what we want
i want sunny d and turkey twizzlers my
jeep run me that i never had
never had turkey twizzlers bro no oh my
god it's the
it was the [ __ ] for school dinners
it was the the food version of sunny d
yeah it was so bad for you never had it
tasted so good
it reminded me of what the i've never
had it but it reminds me of what like
the mcdonald's rib which must taste like
never or the mcrib not the rib which is
the magrib which is what they had on
something
was that only in america was that here
was that the magrib they've never had
the hair i'm sure yeah
that's why i said it was that only yeah
yeah that's what i said yeah only in
america
yeah but it was one of them their magrib
is like
our big tasty that only comes out now
and again
yeah yeah yeah but i don't even like to
be tasty remember i'm sure they did uh
or did they do a mcrib episode
in rick and morty you know it was the
curry sauce thing that the
sweet
it was the mulan sauce mulan's
um what sauce was it i can't
remember bro you if you guys watched
richard moore you guys know what i'm
talking about
what sauce was it i don't know mulan
morty
they went to a next dimension together
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's there in
the car
i need i need to know what it was for
our station i needed to know what it was
oh my days they were back in it like it
was crack cocaine
i don't the thing with like stuff like
mcrib and blah blah blah
you know when they do um szechuan sauce
szechuan
[ __ ] sauce moved on szechuan sauce
i hate the fact that places like
mcdonald's only do specific burgers or
recipes in specific countries bring out
the whole thing my last choose
bro last choose man bro i don't know if
it's a placebo effect
the chips at mcdonald's in france they
stay fresh
[Music]
these french fries in front literally
bro
they stay fresh banging
banging you know when it's when it's
basically looks
white but it's just got a tint of gold
yes piping hot
socks on point i remember the first time
i had it and i was like bro
these are really really french fries
yeah but it must be a placebo effect
yeah because i was in france i was a kid
and i was gasped
but bro when i went to france was a kid
and we went to mcdonald's yeah
son those chips were banging mine called
me sunk
those chips were banging bro homeboy
oh [ __ ] those chips were good
someone from france got a message like
placebo bro the chips suck
chips are bananas yeah if you want
french fries go somewhere else oh you
know what they do in france there's
nothing to the mcdonald's
so they do this thing in france
it's like a staple there it's like a
breakfast baguette
okay so you know like an all-day
breakfast tea yes it's like that
it's almost like a full english in a
baguette okay
bro yeah oh my god
yeah they have it in just food trucks as
you're walking by is this when you were
a kid
yeah you remember this yeah yeah we went
to visit my uncle
yeah and then mahani was taking us like
his fiancee was taking us
yeah okay yeah he's got the french she's
french right
she's friends
[Laughter]
oh yeah
um so yeah she was like oh you boys you
have to taste this
and then like i was like cool was it
it's like like
egg sausage i can't remember had bacon
in there but had mad breakfast meats and
just chips in there bro
ketchup all over the team in one fat
baguette
[ __ ] hell [ __ ] hell bro
banged it oh wow banged it you must have
slapped afterwards
you must have slept off i remember
because my happy was bumping
as well my heavy was bumping that day so
my dad gave me the drowsy
the drowsy happy for tablets we were on
the bus side
i slapped i ate that
geros thing i slapped i can't imagine
slumped on the bus man [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that is hilarious
bro i remember one time
i remember one time when i was a you
where i think my mom yeah
was it my mum that took us or was it my
dad
i can't remember initially i feel like
it was my dad it might be my mum
i think it was my dad i can't remember
but we're on holiday somewhere
or on a coach going somewhere and i
think my dad and my brother sat on this
side
and i had to sit i must have been i
wasn't old enough i hadn't hit puberty
yet but you're at that age where you
acknowledge when women are buff
okay yeah so i might have been like nine
or ten okay
and there was this ting sat down and i
had to sit next to her too
she was like potentially in her 20s
maybe like 18 19 okay
maybe like 20. okay spice
spice i remember thinking oh she's well
you're brought over here abroad okay and
i've been thinking oh she's banging yeah
[ __ ] and i'm nervous i have to sit next
to her like say i'm not a youth yeah
like i'm not a little child so
they're sitting over there i have to sit
here and then
um bro on this coach when i say
slumped and i woke up and i was leaning
up on her like this
i was laying on her shoulder and she
didn't push me off she just let me sleep
there
so when i woke up i woke up like dribble
huh and i looked and she was like
looking down at me like that i was like
oh i'm sorry
she's like oh it's okay it's okay i
looked to my brother he was
smiling
i looked at my brother he was smiling
from ear to ear i wanted to get up and
spark him i wanted to rock his shirt off
do you know for some reason that reminds
me of have you seen modern family right
yeah reminds me of manny manny yeah he
loves
love of all ages you know he loves love
at any age
a man will read poetry to a 25 year old
when you're 13. yeah bro
like that loves women all right he loves
women
but his world is just rejection all he
gets is rejection when he loves women
manny
yeah bro it actually is hilarious comedy
um
you see the one where that i think it's
early seasons
that milf moves in down the road from um
yes and phil can't concentrate when he
got the bike
yeah hill can't concentrate bro
bro tits were swinging bro
oh she was down for man as well she was
down she said
i've locked myself out of the other side
can you come in can you come and help me
climb in the window when come on
come on bro he buckled he
buckled he wanted the bike or stolen
yeah
he wanted to smash through oh my god i
don't blame him
oh yeah yeah and then his wife was like
oh
she's she's a scared like she's already
felt like three of the dads
his eyes peeled and then when i think
they were recycling or jogging and they
crossed paths
yeah yeah yeah tears were he kept on
having he had to look back twice yeah
yeah
i feel dumfy is the funniest character
bro
he loves thingy as well wouldn't it um
gloria gloria
he loves gloria i got gloria
immediately immediately but there was
one time i don't know if you remember
there was one episode where
he he had an arch nemesis back in um
high school obviously he was a
cheerleader back in high school yeah he
was like
nemesis and he all the archaeologists
always used to tease phil
and um i think they they crossed paths
out one place like 10 or 20 years down
down the line and he wanted to impress
this arch nemesis so he felt that he was
married to gloria
i've seen um clothes shopping i've seen
that why i came across the road is like
dory didn't know really
didn't know yeah so he he was playing as
if gloria was the wife gray had no idea
and then he was bragging yeah this is my
thing going vulgar wait till you see her
and then as soon as she left he's like
ah he was like what
ah i always pictured you with claire
dunphy yeah yeah
she was so blagging fashionable you guys
because i felt it for him was like damn
he was ashamed he was ashamed of himself
he was ashamed of himself
such a good wife at home three beautiful
kids and he all you want to do was flex
with gloria
all he wanted to do and then that same
episode i think something happened
and then he was like i think glorian um
i think there was a fight and gloria and
claire both fell down and he's like
i got claire that's the first time in
the whole series he was like
i've got clear crosstalk he felt so
guilty he loves claire
he loves loves he loves banging things
but he loves
his wife there's times where he's
romantic bro
i think there's something like when she
cried she was crying once she was upset
because
she thought like oh i can't remember
that anniversary or valentine's day or
whatever he went
off yeah and she got him nothing yeah no
presents
and then southbound saying that ah this
means that like you love me more
then i love you and he was like i know
that i've always known that
we all know that everyone knows that i
love you more than you love me she was
gutted
she was gutted he's a good man he's a
great man yeah he's a good
man he loves his family boy him and luke
boys
himaluka boys i love their relationship
bro
it's live they're actual boys it's not
father or something yeah
boys they're this life oh man what the
[ __ ] is it
it's a great show that's like uh jay
loves manny in secret in it he loves
money in secret
it touches me he loves to break his
balls but if anyone [ __ ] with manny jay
doesn't
have a pile doesn't have it he doesn't
have a slice of it yeah man
yeah that's such a good chance yeah yeah
such a good choice and i love the name
actual modern family because they're all
it is the modern fact
they're all a family but they're all it
is a modern family you've got a gay
a couple in there you've got like
obviously older and younger
you've got like the stepmom who's
younger than the it's [ __ ] modern
family
it's weird but it's so good all the
characters paddling so well
all the characters even um
kevin um the other picture
mitchell mitchell they're adopted
filipino daughter yeah
hilarious the one liner she comes out
with both she's funny
cam sweets me he's one of the funniest
guys
sweet species he's so sensitive
he reacts to any and everything do you
see where he's working the cycle shots
his death was just to the left
the man said get rid of the shots he was
upset
he cries for everything i hate your
beard
shave it and then he was going to let it
down and he was peeking through the top
let's
see if he's going to shave it and he's
like
stop stop stop and he's like oh why
don't you shave mine and he turned on to
try and shave his back
that's dex is that awesome we're doing
this and you walked out
cam is so dramatic he's so dramatic and
so funny oh
can't switch me when he said let's do
mine
do you mind i went to do his back oh my
god
he's gobsmacked
he can't believe he when he gets
everybody he
physically can't believe that someone
has the audacity to offend him in that
capacity yeah
oh it's funny bro oh wow
modern family is one of the funniest
shows i've ever watched
it's hilarious bro it's hilarious i've
spent hours watching that before
i laugh watching that i was saying i
can't stop sometimes
you know i've never actually finished it
because on netflix stops on season
eight or nine maybe i think it's eight
but it got nine ten eleven which isn't
on netflix and i've never seen it
really never see i don't know i couldn't
find them bro lily must be like 15 and
then
everyone's old bro and um jay's son i
can't remember his name the little
little one
you know he had another kid with gloria
oh yeah he did what's his name
i don't know because he he gave him an
english name in the middle
yeah yeah he calls himself english
he does call him joe hence
oh funny but yeah i've never seen the
last three seasons and i really want to
watch them
don't know why they're not netflix
because i will binge that
i [ __ ] love that show yeah man money
off that show
speaking of i was doing because when i
watch um
shows back to back-to-back i like to
google stuff about them and like the
characters and blah blah and obviously
that's how i found out there are more
seasons
did you know that jay pritchett um has a
black belt in jiu jitsu
really yeah i knew that was interesting
i knew they were interesting yeah is
this black belt
black belt jujitsu and gloria at the
time was the highest paid
actress in the world yeah yeah yeah yeah
i didn't know that um
um what are the daughters names um
alex alex had to have a breast reduction
yeah she had 15. she's got
titties she puberty
she had um you know she's engaged right
now
in real life how is it um she either has
a pacemaker or has
a hole in her something like she has
surgery no claire has a pacemaker which
she has to wear
like in real life and haley had to have
something removed or she had cats or
something like that
that's why she's always slim like in
real life she's so slim because she had
something
wrong with her oh she has to keep
getting checked up and stuff to be fair
i was wondering she's
bet like bro i googled them stuff about
that i was like damn these are
interesting facts luke's a
genius isn't he i did not know that did
you not know that no i didn't know that
luke's that's the main fact that i know
about the show in real life the guy who
plays luke is actually like his iq is
ridiculously high
really he's actually like incredibly
smart
that's crazy because obviously alex is
portrayed as the smartest one in the
show
yeah luke is a genius crazy oh wow yeah
that's okay that can be a fun fact
that's what i was going to say this is
already a fun fact as it is
yeah i knew that black girl jiu jitsu
will sweet you oh yeah bro
that's no easy feat that's 10 years plus
bro he's 75
is he yeah he makes money he makes um
what was i gonna say he um
who else is decent at jiu jitsu
they're going to just do such an
interesting thing because it's like
it's so difficult that if you are
it's like one of them things that's like
if someone's a higher belt than you
it's categorical so same for examples
say for example someone's boxed for
seven years and someone else has bought
for five years
boxing's so based so much based on
athletic ability
that you can smack up someone who's been
doing it five years longer than you
do what i mean based on like weight and
all these other things as well and if
you're just more naturally gifted and
stuff like that you smack someone up
except for extreme examples in jujitsu
if someone is a higher belt than you
categorically they can smack you up
categorically they can [ __ ] you up you
have to put respect on them
you have to bro when you're doing just
you if someone
is a higher level than you they're it
9.9 times out of 10
that person if you will [ __ ] you up
so russell brand is a blue belt okay i
don't know so obviously i haven't
introduced you in like
forever now yeah so i haven't even
managed to get near my blue belt
but i have um but like i'm just i'm just
so far out of the game what's the first
spell is it white star is white okay so
it goes in like a stripe system so you
get your white belt and you're on
nothing
and then as you develop you get what
they call stripes they put stripes on
your belt once you get to four stripes
then you get a blue belt and then four
stripes purple belt four stripes
uh brown belt four stripes black belt
also there's only four colors
so there's yeah white blue purple brown
black and then you get
stripes in between oh wow um so sorry to
cut you off can you be
a black belt with stripes so yes
um and then you you start going through
the black belt rank black belt rankings
um and then yeah there's like there's
like this
really special belt which is like uh
what color is it it's like a it's like a
reddy color
um coral they call it coral bell which
is only like gifted to you by like
the gracie families the greatest
families the people who invented
brazilian jiu jitsu
and then you have to be to get a call
about you have to be like
you've been doing it for like 40 years
and like you're you're deep in the game
and then you're like considered like a
master
and then you go out to brazil and then
gracie will
give you like your coral battle there's
only a few of them man in the world
one of them night intakes basically
basically yeah yeah
you're undefeated like you're a maid man
if you're a cobalt like you know
like you no one's anything um yeah back
to russell brand new belt wrestle yes
and russell brown is a blue bell
yeah which means it doesn't matter it
doesn't
matter like what i think about russell
brand
it doesn't matter if i think it's a
[ __ ] it doesn't matter if
anything i'm glad you said russell brown
because he's a great example he's a
great example
of if you said any anyone oh do you
think you could smack up muscle brad
everyone was like yes yeah yeah but if
you're fighting jiu jitsu
russell brown will beat you that's a
fact the fact that he's been given a
bluebell
he will beat you and there's nothing you
can say or do about it
it's a fact i don't even know i've never
even seen him roll i've never seen him
jujitsu but the fact that his bluebell
insures me that he will beat me that's
why
that's a fact that's a fact that's wild
i think i've been able about one time
yeah yeah
that's wild how did that fight go well
uh kind of but yeah this guy is like
it's at least like an exception in my
opinion he's someone who i feel like got
the blue back when they didn't deserve
the blue belt
but he pays a lot of money for like
private sessions and all this stuff
and he knows the techniques and all that
stuff but
he's just not good he thinks he's good
okay
so my brother here my brother cause i
can't remember this guy's actual name
yes i can't but i'm not gonna pay it out
my brother calls him aids luke his name
ain't luke
he just calls him aids luke luke has a
nick dunphy or just because
no he just calls this guy at traditions
like aids like
aids like hiv luke why
because he's so annoying that he's like
aids
oh my man says he is aids and he looks
like someone
he's a white guy he looks like a luke
aids luke
hey's luke that's what he calls him he
knows his name now
his real name but we didn't even know
it's economics he didn't we had no idea
what this guy's name was right he was so
annoying bro
so annoying he thought he was so sick
that any time that you tapped him out
he'd have an excuse as to why hmm like
oh yeah yeah yeah
i see what you did there yeah i was
gonna get out of it but
like you know that's what yeah he's one
of them
he lives in a world of denial a world of
denial cam
yeah bro he doesn't want it he's so
trash as well so he got his rebound
because he's been doing it for ages and
then just it was just like a sympathy
blue bell at this point
so i [ __ ] him up um but he's not he's
he's good enough that he'd [ __ ] up like
most people
or like anyone who doesn't do it they
put them up he's not [ __ ]
but just like yeah he yeah i wasn't i'm
not losing brush i don't like them so
much i'm like i'm not losing
i'm not doing this yeah yeah yeah yeah
but like
uh ashton kutcher is a purple belt okay
so again i should give you a ruin my
life bro
ruin my life oh wow if me and nathan
kutcher hit the mat
will [ __ ] me up and that's just a that's
just what i have to accept yeah
i would not have suspected he was of any
doubt
no and now bro 75 year old jack
pritchard
from modern family black belt blue oh
who [ __ ] you up 75 is don't matter
doesn't matter bro there's a [ __ ] old
black belt judo guy
that used to come to my club called
clive
[ __ ] me up every week old man old ass
man bro
ruined my life [ __ ] man
yeah dude that's good it's that's a good
sport to be in there
it's great oh it's great it's so
humbling
but i've had little ass girls [ __ ] me
bro you said so
[ __ ] me you said something i'm gonna
break my arm
i'd be living i'll be shaking bro you
have to take those treats because it
won't be judicious anymore
it wouldn't i couldn't do it i couldn't
do jiu-jitsu i guess so i'd be too
quickly
you wouldn't i don't think you would
because you it's one of them
no one's most people are like very
humble about it
so no one's doing it to be an [ __ ]
there's ways you can do it
to be a dick and that pisses people off
but there's ways that you can do it when
you're losing you're just like
so this is kind of like a grace in the
defeat yeah bro okay and it's
like cool and then as soon as you get
tapped out you say cool you reset you go
straight back in again it's not over so
as soon as someone attaches it's not
like okay
you've been tapped like move on it's
like cool you're gonna be sparring for
five
ten minutes okay however many times she
attaches up to you and stuff like that
so if they're gracious by it if they
know they're better than you
then they're going to take it easy to
you and they're going to let you get
yourself into the positions that you
want to get
and obviously they just flow with it
nicely it's just nice like humble
um but yeah some people can be dicks
about it and that's when you think let's
take it outside
i spot a couple of people like this yeah
yeah yeah complete one side let's just
take it outside
if it's the one of them just take
outside
it's not jujitsu anymore yeah yeah
there's a couple minutes there's a
couple minutes
yeah that's cool that's cool that's
discipline boy
um but yeah man um
god we've been chin wagging i was
thinking i want to ask you
obviously you know we always talk about
this like work life
this work life when do you ever remember
the first time
in your life having a job where you're
like
what am i doing here like this ain't it
um probably
one when i did that um door-to-door
salesman thing for a week in uni
from like the second to thirty or first
or second year and i did that for a week
and i was like what am i doing here
because i remember that that was when we
were going to live in grafton i believe
and probably i'm trying to think about
other jobs i did have
i worked in you before then
prior to that nothing else really sticks
out maybe that made me delight
because that's what i knew like that's
what i knew
like nine to five just wasn't for me bro
i can't sit down in the office doing
this
it's dead after lunch after manager
always wants to sleep i don't know
what i'm doing i don't know how you men
are doing it cuz
i've got my little slidey on my juice
i'm gonna
after lunch crash here is renowned bro i
want a kid
i used to have to go for a walk i used
to have to go for a walk around a lake
bro i would um i would have my lunch
be like okay i'm tired don't want to be
wrong right go to the toilet
kit and go to the toilet and just put my
head on the tee
and kip bro i'll be missing for like
half an hour
so i don't know how you might do how
even active after lunch i don't get it
but i wasn't
active bro i was not active so i'm
knackered when i get there
and then all i'm doing i'm waiting for
lunch i'm waiting for us one one hits
one 1pm rolls around i eat my food i'm
like
i'm done for the day i'm done for the
day i have to be here till four or five
you've been having a bubble bath you men
are having a [ __ ] bottle bath bro
because i'm not on it i'm just not on it
oh my god worst times in my life oh my
god
and it was every day yeah bro lunch was
every day so i was tired every day
monday to friday this is a new session
listen
listen bro finally someone understands
bro
i thought i was crazy i was in the
office thinking i'm
i must be crazy because every matter of
fact
and i wanted to get up and scream like
this is [ __ ] hell
this is hell we're in hell do you guys
not get it wake up
we're in hell bro this is it
it didn't make sense to me this is hell
guys wake up let's get out of here
please quick grab your things this is
not a drill we're inheriting
your things let's go bro we're in hell
this is awful man it's made no sense bro
and all you hear is everyone's like
and you just wanna
bro so annoying so
annoying you bump into someone in the
[ __ ] kitchen you're right
they're like i'll be better when it's
friday
the same monotonous the same [ __ ] every
day roll nine to five is [ __ ]
wank yes bro when five o'clock used to
roll around
because some people were on like a
slightly later shift yeah i mean i think
i told you
yeah some people would do so it would be
some people would do an eight four
nine five and it wasn't even intense
because i think it was just like half
nine high five bro
if i was on that eight four when four
got rolled around i
was bumping bro i was out of there i
don't know
i used to tell everyone enjoy this [ __ ]
bro cause i'm
out everyone's are you such an idiot
[ __ ] off and i'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you i'm gone last tuesday you know
i'll be back tomorrow tomorrow but i
literally just feel like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you this is [ __ ] i'm out
[ __ ] you i hate it oh go and enjoy this
enjoy this next hour bro
because this is hell and i'm done i wish
i cuz i've never i've obviously
heard you say this to me like two or
three or four times but i wish i saw it
oh yeah bro i don't know why i just wish
i saw it i've never seen that sliding
bro i
i felt like an alien i was just like how
are people just getting on with this i
know
and then up with it bro and then this
after lunch crashing you talk about
is to rest my head on the thing i used
to crack open the monster and drink the
whole thing
and it did nothing when you're in you
know
you know you know we talked about loki
the other day yeah he said his powers
don't work in the tva
bro a nine to five office is literally
the tv
and you do the rewinding yeah that's it
that's it
every day they just rewind you back to
where you were yesterday you sit in your
desk and you're like
and i'm just staring there and i'm
thinking if that phone rings i'm gonna
kill someone
and then it just rings and you're like
i'm gonna put my head through this table
like i hate it here bro i hate here so
much someone get me out of here
and you can't say it to anyone i know
it's such a monotonous world man we're
not in this
class the [ __ ] are you yeah and they
just they just they just
get it and i don't get it and they just
but they just accept it and i used to
sit there just moan about it
and just be like bro this nine to five
thing is so [ __ ]
like what are we doing here amanda's
like
like you're so funny like and i'm like
bro
i'm not funny you know i'm not joking i
need to be out of here i don't want to
be here dog ah
but yeah um long story short nine to
five office work is hell
yeah it's hell enough you guys are doing
it
props but it's just not for us man it's
just not
but that's how you say you don't know
how i do hospitality it's just i
can't do nine to five i can't the amount
of people that
i've spoken to is that i don't know how
you do these late shifts of blah blah
repetition the same way we ask how do
people do nine to five repetition you
know yeah yeah yeah
used to that life the way i'm so used to
the hospitality life i just can't sit
down at a desk
just type and type and type in typing
from nine or five one o'clock have food
and just be
knackered because the chairs are comfy
the chairs are built for me to sleep
at lunch time after i have a sandwich
yeah yeah yeah
yeah there needs to be like a siesta
room yeah bro
it was like a night or something that
have that in it yeah yeah they do they
do
it promotes um productivity productivity
that's what i was looking for it does
productivity
it does it was like a cheeky nine to
seven and gave me a two hour nap after
lunch
i could pan that i'm not gonna lie to
you i could patent
i could i probably could as well
i could patent that yeah i'm staying
until seven if you give me a two hour
kick but i'll have these three two seven
one till three siesta i could plan that
bro
happily i'm vex at five o'clock i'm not
like oh bro
i'm vex at five o'clock i'm gonna leave
oh i'm out of there
i'm out of there um let me do
and i'm the [ __ ] okay i found a good
one
so madman said hey guys
love your pod yeah i've gotten the mind
of the [ __ ] for you yeah
so basically my friend set me up with
this thing and i ended up seeing her for
about two months
yeah and i felt like it was going
nowhere
so i tried to end it off nicely by
pushing her away
is that nice how is that nice i don't
know i don't know bro i don't know
i said fast forward three months prior
to the last time we'd spoke
she messages me out of the blue and is
uh asking about the last time we spoke i
can't i don't i don't really know what
that means
but basically she messes mother blue
chat chat yeah yeah at first i was
trying to be nice
but afterwards i asked her straight if
she wanted to be dtf
um down to [ __ ] if you don't understand
she said she was okay with it and we
carried on talking for a week with
flirty stroke dirty texts
with a date set up for the link on the
day i'm supposed to link her she stands
me up
and sends a massive paragraph saying how
she felt disrespected about the way i
asked her if she was down
the funny part about all of it is she
wanted
uh to be friends with benefits but it's
just the way i asked her
so my question is am i the [ __ ] for
my actions or not
um i think
kind of yes because you said at the
beginning she said
um he didn't like i said he pushed her
away that's the way he broke up with her
yeah i think from that alone
it's the dumbest thing to say it's a
dumbest thing to do like if you don't
like how you're gonna
why would you push them away just yeah
big man this ain't working yeah yeah
yeah they pushed them away yeah so by
pushing her away and then when you said
three months or three weeks down the
line wherever it was
you guys started to speak again and you
asked if she's down to [ __ ]
she's obviously going to figure a
[ __ ] prick in my assumption true but
she says yeah
of course she said yeah because well not
of course she said yes but i understand
she said yes
she fancies the guy in it like she wants
to [ __ ] like everyone's human you know
and women also don't like to women like
to recycle
women don't like to add to their to
their number oh yeah that's their
highest yeah
they like to recycle yeah so if an x
flame is saying
let's have a good time it's
understandable but maybe she was feeling
some type of way
you know when it's basically having um
um
what's the word i'm looking for um
personal clarity yeah
so after you bust a nut you're like
maybe i shouldn't have sent that text
yeah yeah you know yeah so maybe she was
thinking after the
after the heat at the moment about these
back and forth are three months down the
line after
the exchange of our sex this like this
dirty talk chat whatever and then it
actually came today maybe she started
thinking or maybe she spoke to a friend
of offlade offloaded everything to her
it's like
what do i do should i go blah blah and
the friend was probably in her ear like
yo he's treating you like a mug i think
you should lock it so i can understand
i can understand why she said what she
said and i can understand why
he may feel like he's the [ __ ] as
well so i think it's there's both
parts to play in there i think that i
would agree there's a hundred percent
both past the player now i would say
um
i think the only [ __ ] thing he's
done is in my opinion
was the initial like i wasn't fitness so
i pushed her away kind of thing
rather than just being upfront about
look i'm desire trying to smash people
um if you're down with that then cool
but not yeah not like i'm not really fit
in this
i would want to keep like banging her
but i'm not really feeling it
and then push her away um and then when
she comes back think yeah yeah i can
pattern like i smash out this
that's like that's kind of dirty that's
a bit assholey but yeah on the same time
she's an [ __ ] as well because
obviously she's saying so he said are
you trying to do a friend's benefits
team
i don't know how he asked her or
whatever but in that moment she said
yeah i'm down
and then they were sending flirty texts
for like a week all this all this
setting up let's set up a date kind of
thing to do it so she went along with it
for a whole week
said we're going to link up on this day
and then on the day she just stood him
up yeah
and then said then decided to have a
conscience and say i don't like the way
you spoke to me about this
i said it a week ago you had this
conversation on monday i said that a
week ago and i've been getting nude
since
so why are you now vex about it yeah
what's going on he wasn't vexed about it
last week
so why are you investigating now and you
wait till today to stand me up to tell
me that
was this your ploy the whole time were
you ever gonna come you would have been
so
limited oh hundred percent 100 bro
100 there's nothing worse than knowing
you're getting dick or [ __ ] on that day
and the freight to cancel
there's nothing worse and then she just
berates you
not only did she cancel she cusses you
out nah man
nah man that's annoying that's annoying
yeah i just don't like the idea that she
caught conscience on the day
just like oh i don't actually like the
way that you address this with me and
she's like you could have said that ages
ago she obviously spoke to my brother
yeah yeah and like if it could have been
something that we could have
spoke about like if you're like oh yeah
you could have just been like i am down
but like
you can't be asking you can't be talking
to people like that and he would have
been like oh yeah sorry like
it's not even like that kind of thing
you know he could have he could have had
a chance to defend himself
exactly exactly you can give him that
chance he didn't give him the chance to
bend himself
as if she said in the armor the answer
yes true it's true
i think they're both ourselves they're
completely i think they're both
yeah it does they both did [ __ ]
things yeah um and that's that so
is that one um but yeah you're happy to
rap happy to wrap guys
um episode 100 next week century up
guys we'll see you there we'll see you
there
[Music]